well John you you were telling me about
the situation I know where there was you
were in Cuba or a friend was in Cuba
when the word came down the to cover it
yeah a friend of a friend of mine an
acquaintance of mine that I met since I
got out of the sea I was passing through
town and he had been there covering the
non-aligned nations conference he was a
rider or order he as a writer yes
working on a magazine in in Washington a
controversial magazine but he was there
as a reporter with the reporters
covering the conference they got the the
various reporters got instructions from
their offices in Washington and New York
to find out about the Soviets in Cuba
and they sent back messages according to
him all of them saying you've got to be
kidding this has got to be some kind of
a grand put on and they got terse
messages back from their headquarters
saying it's it's the big story of right
now do it find out about the Soviets in
Cuba and they couldn't believe it it was
it was an international joke literally
now let's back up a big step and note
what what nobody brought out and they
certainly could have and that's that the
the subject the issue of Soviet troops
in Cuba was a spinoff an evolution of a
CIA operation to disrupt and manipulate
the non-aligned nations conference Fidel
Castro was managing this conference is
hosting it on in Cuba near America which
which is a difference and he's the old
enough Matoo the CIA the CIA tried to
kill him so many times unsuccessfully 20
years unable to rid itself rid the
United States of this communist leader
on our shores and this year the the
non-aligned nations conference is
meeting in Havana hosted by Castro the
CIA went all out the thing they seized
on as an issue to discredit Castro was
to make him appear to be not non-aligned
he's aligned with the Soviet Union which
is probably true it's it's probably his
Achilles heel as a non-aligned nations
leader is that he is aligned with the
Soviet Union
how better could the CI bring this out
and to make a big issue of Soviet troops
in Cuba and it's been leaked out if you
read these various articles in Time
magazine in the New York Times in the
Washington Post and elsewhere you notice
that it is admitted that the CIA was
working with the National Security
Council the national security adviser
Brzezinski
on the subject of the conference the
upcoming conference and they did seize
on the presence of Soviet troops in Cuba
as an issue and in exactly during the
conference they make this this dramatic
announcement of Soviet troops in in Cuba
now what is brought out in bits and
pieces but not very well by the media
and covering this by the statements that
were quoted is that it there was no
threatening Soviet presence in Cuba no
one at any point pretended that the US
was national security was being
jeopardized by a Soviet force that could
invade Florida or Puerto Rico or
anywhere else it was a trivial of 2,000
men approximately a lot of cymatics were
played on whether or not they were
combat troops at well I would react by
saying that they were in fact combat
troops but combat troops are also
instructors so the Soviets may be
telling the truth there but they were
their infantry troops but they are not
assault troops even President Carter and
one of his speeches admitted this they
didn't have they they do not have the
delivery capability the ships airplanes
helicopters however to move from Cuba to
Florida or Puerto Rico somewhere else
they're not assault troops they don't
have an aggressive posture or capability
they don't have the weapons that would
go with an assault unit the press
dramatized this issue by talking and you
notice these commentators the the drama
that they would get in their voices
where they would say Soviet troops in
Cuba you know and it makes you want to
sit up and get nervous if they had said
this tiny Soviet forcing cube every time
they brought it up or something like
that it would have put it into its true
perspective
something else well John do you think
they manufactured the story then that
we've known that there's been Soviet
troops in Cuba since 1962 definitely
there was something like 40,000 troops
at that time and most were withdrawn but
there's been two or three thousand
troops there continued the whole time
and Vance is the Secretary of State's
first the administration's first
announcement of this as being an issue
objected to the status quo he did not
object to the introduction of Soviet
troops into Cuba he said the status quo
is unacceptable because he knew that the
Soviets knew and the Cubans knew that we
knew that they had been there the whole
time there was nothing new about this
issue the only thing that was new was
the non-aligned nations conference
happening right but did the media
adequately point out that no new cute
Russian troops were actually recently
placed in Cuba didn't they give the
impression from the news clippings that
this was something new something
threatening oh I've been dangerous as if
Russia had recently put a whole flock of
new troops there that suddenly pose the
threat sir so this is this is really
distortion of the grossest magnitude
because it's exercising the American
people it's jeopardizing salt notice
also that every one of the the Senators
and and other individuals that are
quoted there has some major vested
interest in making an issue out of this
except perhaps senator Byrd salt won't
go said church unless the troops are out
and presidential hopeful Baker said he
won't be able to remain silent if the
troops aren't out soon
now he too has the guts to do something
about it or he doesn't oh there's no
need to look at this as though it's a
crisis I was here in the 1962 crisis
I've been here in some pretty tense
moments but there's no crisis here
scoop Jackson is the original hawk
always clamoring for more arms in a
more dramatic US military posture Baker
of course in Goldwater traditionally
critics of the Democratic administration
Baker with his own presidential
aspirations both of them conservative
both of them looking for issues that
they can stir it up to to egg the
administration on to challenge the
Soviets to the Hawks were able to play
this issue into a situation which which
apparently is going to lead has led and
is going to lead to an escalation of
military activity in the Caribbean and
greater defense spending we now have in
in the press today two thousand more US
Marines being put into Guantanamo Bay on
Cuban soil and other marine military
maneuvers in the Caribbean it's been it
was a field day for the for the Hawks
done is another Hawk five percent
military budget increase Frank Church of
course is a traditional liberal but he's
in jeopardy of losing his position in
the new elections his state I believe
it's Idaho has turned conservative under
him and so he was back when this was
launched he he was advised of it over
scrambled telephone while he was back in
Idaho campaigning and he his reaction is
has been quoted abundantly that he said
I can't sit on this I can't keep the
secret Soviets in Cuba I've got to come
out with it and the answer from the
administration was we realized that
meaning obviously I called him while he
was home while he was on this ultra
conservative kick to giving them an
ammunition so he would bring it out and
make an issue of it
Carter's objectives are fairly clear hit
at the point that crisis non crisis
broke he had never been lower in the
polls his political future was and still
is very much in doubt and he needed some
issue that he could some crisis are
preferably awful sounding non crisis
that he could thump his chest and show
how macho he is in
doubling this non-crisis and so he did
but didn't this backfire in some ways
against Carter because because he wasn't
able to effectively do anything about it
that is he couldn't get the Russians to
remove the troops that it made him look
weak again all the networks made this is
what I surprised me by looking at the
coverage of it the network's constantly
made Carter look like a fool the
president sought counsel from the
congressional delegation to the
distinguished Jacob Javits mr. Carter
said what would you do
replied you mean you called us here at
8:30 in the morning to ask us what we
would do what are you gonna do senators
and congressmen were told the u.s. asked
for Soviet Union if the troops were
combat troops answer from Moscow no the
u.s. asked if they would take the troops
out anyway answer no another answer to
the same question is expected within a
few days inquiry how many days president
two or three days Vance not that fast
Javed's can we have another meeting yes
within a week Vance not that fast that
is what you call your basic linkage
between Cuba and salt even those sources
said the meeting was told the United
States still does not know why the
Soviet troops are there and we do not
know exactly how serious it all is
another doesn't accuse the president of
trying to have it both ways of being
hard on one hand and soft on the other
according to this source the meeting was
not very enlightening or satisfying
Senate Democratic majority leader robert
byrd didn't even bother to attend the
meeting with the president Byrd claimed
that he had received a briefing from
secretary Vance last night the result of
today's meeting the President did win
some more time however he did not
generate much confidence in his
leadership the president hopes this
policy will convince hardliners
particularly those in the Senate who are
holding the salt treaty hostage that he
has effectively neutralized the Russian
troops while at the same time proving
anew that he does not panic in a crisis
& risk general war but already the
president's plan has hit one tiny snag
mister Carter wanted to go on television
Sunday night and where did that leak so
widely in Washington that one
afternoon newspaper here headline the
Carter talk on Cuba on Sunday then the
White House discovered that Sunday was
the High Holy Jewish holiday Yom Kippur
and so in some confusion it rescheduled
a speech for Monday night Sam Donaldson
ABC News the White House gave a lot of
TV network coverage to Connolly and
Baker and these right-wing Republicans
attacking Carter for being soft so I
think Carter really lost politically on
this one also after then he had the
speech that Carter made where he
outlined his plan immediately the
headlines and the 10 o'clock news were
Russian troops to stay in Cuba as if
Carter had not really done anything and
therefore failed to be a strong leader
well isn't there a certain justice in
that because this this whole thing
started with an operation Brzezinski and
the CI Jun DUP to embarrass Cuba and the
Soviets and but president would they
work for President Carter the the CIA is
part of the White House and and and
Carter permitted it apparently
encouraged it to be brought brought out
and made public and made into an
international issue and in that sense
it's backfiring on him is a certain
amount of justice he had secretary Vance
make the statements and say make an
issue out of it throw the gauntlet down
say the status quo is unacceptable and
the amateurish necessitous tration was
was shown right then and there
in that the status quo was unchangeable
by the United States except this this
very weak solution came up at in the end
well we can't do anything about the
Soviets in Cuba so we'll increase our
own military activity around you always
wonder how much something like this was
planned ahead of time since it had so
much of an effect of encouraging the
Hawks and leader leading to greater
military activity and spending how much
of it was was determined ahead of time
let's let's make an issue of the Soviet
troops there so we
can get into this defense spending
particularly since they'd known about it
for 17 years since they've known about
it for 17 years well I noticed
frequently that they would toss around
the CIA as well we have good
intelligence I got a briefing by
Stanfield turner blah blah they would be
bringing it in as if that would
automatically give the stamp of
expertise on it I was just in a briefing
with Stanfield Turner the head of the
CIA a few moments ago and he believes
that those troops are not there just to
Train Cubans
however we do not know the mission of
those troops early this morning National
Security Council members including CIA
director Turner and Secretary of State
Vance arrived to continue talks with the
president which went on here until late
last night about Senator Baker
suggestion that the president now
release intelligence photographs of the
Soviet troops in Cuba ABC news
diplomatic correspondent Barrie Dunsmore
reports the State Department will oppose
doing that while negotiations are still
under way but if the talks break down
release of the evidence might be a good
idea
it's amazing how they would dare to do
that when you have this history of
incredible endless intelligence failures
by the CIA in crisis after crisis after
crisis the CIA coming up with faulty or
false information and for them to cite
Stansfield Turner in a situation like
this remember the last us-cuban
confrontation where where President
Carter was calling President Castro a
liar and vice versa
was a year and a half ago at the time
cutting he's invaded the shaba and
President Carter said that we had
intelligence that it was a Cuban
operation and Castro said it absolutely
was not a Cuban operation that it was
kotani's and Cuba had nothing to do with
it and President Carter did much as they
had there he had CIA you know the CIA
had information proving it eventually it
was resolved by some senators going down
to Van and meeting with Castro
at his invitation and he convinced them
that there was reasonable doubt and they
went back and demanded and were shown
the CIA's intelligence and the 17
senators walked out of that meeting and
said it didn't prove the presence of
Cuba behind that invasion at all in
other words in yet another situation
President Carter was not telling the
truth he was misinformed and he was
distorting the information lying if you
will and Fidel Castro was telling the
truth what amazes me once again is the
absolute distortion of gromicko speech
and the Russians position the Russians
admitted they had troops there and that
they've been there for a long time grim
echo said you know this is a foolish put
up job and let's forget about it and get
on with the business of salt and yet
then the senators who come into the room
echoes lying
he's an absolute liar called it like it
was Soviet foreign minister Andrei
Gromyko today dismissed the American
charge with a short blunt demand forget
it in his speech to the United Nations
General Assembly mr. Gromyko said it was
all part of a campaign to spread lies
about the policies of Cuba and the
Soviet Union but the truth is that this
propaganda is totally without foundation
in reality and our advice on this score
is simple it is high time that you
honestly admit that this whole matter is
artificial and proclaim it to be closed
although mr. Gromyko did not even
mention the presence of Soviet troops in
Cuba it was clear this is what he was
talking about just two weeks ago the
Soviet Union admitted it does have
troops in Cuba but only to train the
Cubans in Soviet military hardware that
their duties and numbers have not
changed in 17 years and that any charges
that organized Soviet combat units have
arrived in Cuba are totally groundless
and mr. Gromyko insisted that there's no
reason for concern the Soviet Union and
other countries of the socialist
community have never threatened anybody
nor are they
opening anybody now this is Luciana ABC
News at the United Nations
Sam Compton at the Capitol where
senators who have seen American
intelligence photos say Gromyko is lying
I'm astonished
there is simply no basis for doubting
that the Soviet Union that the Russians
have a fully equipped fully manned
combat Brigade in Cuba I would hope that
the president now would consider
releasing the very very reliable
intelligence data we have including
aerial aerial and satellite photography
to conclusively show that there are
Russian combat troops in Cuba each
senator pointed out that Gromyko was
involved in another Cuban dispute the
1962 missile crisis I think the the
president really has to be firm in this
and just remind American people that
this is the same mr. Gromyko who lied
about missiles he was caught red-handed
and I regret that mr. Gromyko has seen
fit to state a bald-faced lie that's
what it is
grim eCos intervention has had a
chilling effect on the strategic arms
treaty with the Soviets a growing number
of senators including a man in control
of the treaty Foreign Relations chairman
Frank Church say that unless the
president can soon certify that the
Russian combat forces have been
dismantled the salt treaty will be put
on ice it was not a good day today for
the United States at the United Nations
because lying
he's an absolute liar called it like it
was he said that they were there he said
they were not assault troops but they
were there for training and certainly we
have troops all over the world that are
there to help install our and train and
use our military equipment the hardware
we've installed we had for many years
this huge unit in in Addis Ababa
we have of course 5,000 troops on the
Soviet border in Turkey
these troops have no capability of
invading Russia for heaven's sake but
they are combat troops we've all been
trained in how to shoot rifles and what
and I would say that the only two people
I saw in there who seemed to be candidly
caught three I guess calling it like it
was was Senator Byrd who said it was an
on crisis Gromyko it appeared to me
called it like it was said you're making
something out of nothing for your own
purposes and then Fidel Castro also
calling it like it was and and Andrew
Young also and Andrew Young yes EK
nosotros llamamos central instruction
which we call training center they tie
Guba the dsm-v a CCA there has been in
Cuba
for the past 17 years Scientology
leaders now then that military facility
quick riad al final de la Chrissy
doctora de minimis into sin was
established at the end of the October
crisis amino CentOS say Cindy goes in
1962 conformally para todo hoc ergo in
conformity with the spirit of the
agreement edition you sign on October of
that year
if dentro dello stato table sido como
consecuencia de la Krishnan within the
Storrow school that was set up as a
result of the October crisis here why
has he brought this problem going right
now to create a situation okay let you
look at English eventually the character
that protest situation is in a crisis
Nala rather a chopper SD not given the
right to place peace into a crisis is
European chocolate rush in the car and
I'll deal with the current that Carter's
behavior concerning your problem a
syllabus Tony has been dishonest as he
doing since it has been on sincere
acidic Maura has been immoral yes
angandjen dollop in you and you leak a
moody receiving the world public opinion
yellow panel polygit ocean and the US
public opinion Andrew Young bowed out as
a diplomat speaking his mind as usual
last night he spoke to 5,000 blacks and
at a time when the administration has
been saying it's gravely concerned over
those Soviet combat troops in Cuba young
ridiculed the threat if the Russians
made a move against us our defenses are
strong enough to ignore and
wipe out and obliterate some 3000 Cubans
and I mean Russians and Cuba what the
hell can they do to the United States of
America
that is a totally irrelevant political
issue that has nothing to do with the
national security of this nation more
relevant young said is inflation and
unemployment more of a threat than
troops in Cuba then young philosophized
about what he thinks is wrong with
foreign policy it's not some amorphous
strategic concept decided by some folk
that ain't never fought no Wars don't
know nothing about suffering never been
poor and essentially in isolate
themselves in some ivory tower writing
papers and theorizing to each other
those are the folks those essentially of
a folk that have created the mess that
the world is now in Andrew Young's
beautiful comments and the other people
well John don't you think that the
network news is irresponsible in failing
to give this broader context for the
story and leaving out the fact that this
was a story based on leaks that really
gave no new information in the way they
played this up night after night and
gave all these Hawks such a pervasive
coverage you know our enemies overseas
we talked about communist censorship of
the press and the Communists talk about
our censorship of the press or our press
working for the government and as we sit
here we find this an incredible charge
from the Communists because we know that
we have freedom of the press you can go
out and start a newspaper with a
mimeograph machine and print more or
less what you want and you probably
won't be eliminated the next day by the
FBI although that has been known to
happen but the fact is that while you
can't claim plausibly and I wouldn't
that the New York Times or The
Washington Post our Time magazine or
Newsweek the biggies are actually
controlled by the administration not in
a sense of the administration calling
them up and saying here's our line on
this issue everybody do it the press
plays directly into the hands
the administration it's the voice of a
given administration the press has
gotten us into incredible situations in
the world devastating situations in the
world such as the Vietnam War if if the
Vietnam War if the press had been
conscientious in nailing the
administration on its lies and
distortions during the Vietnam War
during the build-up of the Vietnam War
it never would have happened if they had
balked then if they had had interviews
with people and then had someone come on
afterwards saying unfortunately that all
of that is untrue see the press tries it
claims it presents the facts and facts
are if President Carter or scoop Jackson
or Goldwater someone makes a speech that
is a fact that he made that speech and
said those words now the fact that all
those words were false is never
clarified to the public so the
administration can use the press to put
out whatever it wants to on a given
situation and the press will play along
for the sense of drama as they say to
sell newspapers so you have crises like
this that could never have existed if
the press had nailed them at the outset
and said this is nonsense it's a non
crisis there's another irony here in
that during this very period the
Russians went to East Germany in a very
big flourish they said they were going
to take 20,000 Russian troops out of
East Germany and we're going to withdraw
a lot of their forces from Central
Europe and this was hardly covered there
were only seconds of coverage whereas
this seemed to be a major change in
Soviet policy and a potential flaw in
Europe which could be much more
important than this non-event in Cuba
and yet this was barely mentioned this
is how the press can create some stories
and how they don't even cover you've got
to you've got to remember and this is
why I titled my book in search of
enemies it's necessary to our system of
government to have people to oppose and
people to hate if you'll look for
example
I believe it was yesterday President
Carter just finished a small political
swing he made repeated statements about
Cuba
Cuba's aggressive posture Cuba's
military the the Cuba being the the most
militarized country in the world etc
surely we have things that are more
important than Cuba to this nation right
now the collapsing economy the galloping
inflation all of the various minority
groups that are still suffering
persecution in this country he
nevertheless he focuses on Cuba and
makes them into an enemy which they have
no desire to be so that we've got
somebody to hate to oppose so we've got
an excuse to thump our chests and build
up our military machine and he's doing
this obviously as a major element in his
presidential campaign searching for
enemies looking for people that don't
want to fight us that we need to have
somebody to oppose I think there's also
kind of a long range thing that they're
looking forward to here also you read
some books and see some statements by
the high muckety-mucks and they complain
that the Vietnam War has had such a
devastating effect on public opinion
that they can't wheel and deal around
the world now like they used to because
public opinion would not allow it
people would hit the streets again so I
think this is part of an overall policy
of trying to whip up the cold war
rhetoric and look for enemies like you
say so that people will become hawkish
and accept a more a militant stance and
activist stance around the world
as a matter of fact it resulted in the
poll which was mentioned by AP and NBC
Associated Press poll shows Americans by
3 to 1 want the salt treaty held up by
the Senate until the Russian troops are
moved out of Cuba 66% said hold up the
treaty 22% said don't the others didn't
know John how would you comment on
Carter's speech on this incident where
he claimed that Cuba was a puppet a
satellite of the Soviet Union
there was an economic failure do you
think that's an accurate account well
you notice Fidel Castro was on 60
minutes the night before President
Carter's big speech on this subject and
he called President Carter dishonest on
this this subject and then the next
night Carter went on television and it
was almost as though he set out to prove
Castro right his presentation of the
facts was so distorted and he left out
these these glaring omissions that would
give some balance to the thing that
would have explained it and put it into
its perspective things like Cuba's
long-standing and repeated offer
overture to us to normal not normalize
relations which we have consistently
spurned the presence he did not mention
the presence of our marine corps base on
Cuban soil now mind you if the Soviets
had troops on US soil our Cuban troops
on US soil it would be a different thing
but we actually maintained a Marine
Corps base on Cuban soil he made a big
thing out of the Cuba's dependency
economic dependency on the Soviet Union
and he called it Cuba the economic
failure of communism he didn't point out
that we've had a 20-year economic war
against Cuba that it's a long ways from
Russia and it's very close to us this
war has included of course the the
assassination attempts on the leader and
the propaganda efforts to disrupt the
morale of the country but aside from all
that projects to destroy their sugar
crops and and Cuba is almost totally
dependent on its sugar for one thing a
blockade of Cuba for many many years
embargo on the sale of many things to
Cuba we did everything we could to make
them into our enemy and to force them
into the arms of the Soviet Union to
force them to be dependent on the Soviet
Union we could have taken the opposite
policy and tried to help them get
established economically so that they
could be part of the community of
nations and not be aligned with the
Soviet
we pushed them into the arms of the
Soviet Union he didn't bother to point
that out this it's the greatest irony I
think the hardest thing for Americans to
understand and realize and face and
accept is that our presidents have now a
tradition of being the most delicious of
any world leaders our presidents lie the
most as a matter of policy because of
the secrecy establishment now it was it
was absolute proof of the pudding of the
whole thing about the CIA
this was another CIA operation that got
out of hand a rogue elephant they liked
to call them that put that in
jeopardized salt - and put the United
States in the position of being
ridiculed in the eyes of the world and
preoccupied our government for three
weeks until Carter finally did you
notice how when he was on television how
he kept smirking he would be talking
very seriously by all these heavy things
when you kind of give his his little his
little grin he couldn't repress it
because he knew what a jump this whole
thing was their work there was no crisis
but at the same time it had become a
crisis in the sense that salt too was at
stake
well I'll eventually join join us now
we'll proceed with more in-depth
discussion of this and other other items
which might be on your mind it's clear
to me this is a pseudo issue but I'm not
clear of how the CIA is behind it okay
you have to read between the lines only
a little bit to understand the CIA's
role because it has been stated in the
last few weeks I would be more alert to
what these statements meant having been
part of these things before but every
three years there's the the non-aligned
nations conference and every three years
nine months before the conference the
CIA mounts a massive operation to
discredit disrupt and manipulate this
conference in in nineteen whenever it
was 1970 the big issue was China was
trying to get into the United Nations
and we were leaning in the direction of
talking directly to China but the thrust
of the non-aligned nations conference
operation was to get all of the
delegates possible to to oppose
endorsing the entry of China into the
United Nations I was involved in that
when I had an agent who was an
intellectual third world figure who was
a an official in his government who
could go to this conference and so I was
leaned on by headquarters every station
CI station in the world gets these
cables saying not just do you have
anyone who would go but they go through
files back at headquarters and find out
what agents you have and come in and say
send in our intellect to this place and
telling what to say and I got out my
agent and leaned on him and said this is
the line you got to take these of the
China and he said wait a minute he said
wait a minute
my country is very poor
we need China we need a relation with
China you're ordering me to sabotage my
country's interest for one of your
political ploys when everybody can see
that the United States is in the process
of going to bed with China in her own
economic interest he said how can I do
that
indoors - yeah and so I I went back to
headquarters and said that he was not
responsive and so they sort of put an X
on how well he stood as a disciplined
agent and wrote you know little things
about you know I didn't have complete
control of all my agents well we
shouldn't really dismiss the Cuban thing
as being a Mickey Mouse situation here's
what has going to be an increase in
defense spending because of it there's
going to be increased mil during the
president's it'sit's it has turned up
it's a tempest in a teapot but it want
it jeopardized sold I think that will
blow over and people get over that but
it has let it is wound up when we were
moving in the direction of support for
salt and a reduction of strategic
weapons and military posturing that's
that's what these treaties should be
about it has wound up to be a victory
for the Hawks and in the Defense
Department and in the CIA and also this
this is kind of reminiscent of the days
when
would create a threat and go out and
stomp it down and get more money from
Congress in the process isn't the CIA
doing the same thing exactly although I
don't know in them as as I feel I I do
as I did and I believe I still do I
don't think that they are they have
enough mind about there's enough of them
and intellect driving what they do they
always have these non-aligned nations
conference this time it's a biggie
because it's in Cuba and it's the old
CIA nemesis Castro is running it this is
the man to see I tried eight times to
kill he's tried to destroy sugar with
Cuba sugar crops and whatnot he we
forced the CIA's forced him to be
totally dependent on the Soviet Union
economically and he has he has stuck his
finger in the CIA's eye over the years
time and time again and gotten away with
it and he's doing it again 90 miles from
our own Shores so the CIA was obviously
incensed and and by that I when you say
CI in that context you mean the
intelligence establishment because
they're people who don't work in the
language like it's a big new Brzezinski
for example it don't work in the CI but
they're part of the same complex and
it's now it's it's been admitted by the
White House that Brzezinski met with the
CIA for tea committee meetings are the
operations advisory group meetings with
the CI Director and ordered the CI to
focus on Cuba and focus on their
vulnerabilities and focus on Soviets in
Cuba and this was this they admitted
that this began last March and so they
focused on the their operation to
discredit Castro I believe that the CIA
is a moral tragedy and that it's
discredited the United States and it
should be closed down that we should
revert to openness and telling telling
it like it isn't telling the truth to
people I think secrecy doesn't work I
think it masks and provides a cover for
people to do things which would
definitely be unacceptable to the
society at large there's nothing they do
that is forthright positive that you can
stand up in church or wherever you go
and say I'm you know this is what I did
last week and I'm proud of it overseas
it's all your a secret operative that
means your existence there is a lot
you're pretending to be a diplomat or a
scholar or something which are not
you're getting information covertly and
that means I mean we have diplomats in
these countries who talked to people
endlessly if the information is overtly
available they will get it you're there
to bribe and to induce people to be
spies to commit treason and you're also
there to instigate activities meaning
subversion now these are heavy crimes in
every country in the world
normally punishable by death this is
what the CIA does the mass media then
open and willing to discuss your more
radical ideas about abolishing the CIA
are they willing to debate this last
time I talked to you in the phone you
were talking about a letter that you'd
written to the New York Times or a
column for the op-ed page about the
abolition of the CIA did they ever
publish that no the initial reaction of
the press and the mass media to me was
was quite good I would say there was 98
or 99 percent favorable there one
exception was the Washington Post which
is conspicuously Washington
establishment newspaper and very close
to CIA
but since the the initial impact of
publicity of who is john stockwell and
what does he have to say at
simultaneously as the months of track
there's been a change in the stance of
our of our government our establishment
including our press establishment
responding to President Carter's line
and vice president Mondale line and
Admiral Turner's lobbying to get off the
sea ice back and permit it to get back
to work and this is very conspicuous if
you read the editorial sections of the
Washington Post and The New York Times
and Time magazine and Newsweek it's I
mean it's not a covert subtle thing
they're coming out and saying it let's
get off get off the CIA's back and let
them get back to work well of course
work you know for the CIA is is highness
crimes against you met thats their
function that's what this shows
something very just
and that is how the mass media and the
political establishment go along with
the CIA
games that they're duped or are they
willing accomplices how do you read the
role of the media you know I was
complaining about exactly this just a
couple of days ago to a friend of mine
on the New York Times and another friend
on the Washington Post on the
long-distance telephone pointing out
that our press has accepted a stance
which makes it sort of the the willing
participant in such government misdeeds
employees and and blunders what the
press does essentially as they report
they try to report facts there are
obvious biases and whatnot but
essentially they report facts if
President Carter makes a speech the word
it's a fact that he made a speech and
it's a fact that he said this that or
the other the fact that everything he
said is a lie the press doesn't take it
as their responsibility to point that
out so what they do is when a crisis
like this develops they quote they have
you know there's the the fact that the
president said such and so and somebody
else and somebody else in senator church
and Senator Jackson and who was the
senator from Florida and their lies and
miss state's statements and
exaggerations are become the issue even
though they're false and even though
everyone involved in the press knows
that they're false no one in the press
points us out to the readers this seemed
even the editors write their columns
rarely tackle the President or the
Secretary of State or even an admiral
Turner
they will take him on some time but they
Rick how often do you read and an
article did you after the the
President's speech the other night about
this crisis where was there any
editorial in a major newspaper that said
that he lied on point after point after
point well you know I think John pointed
out before when he was on the show that
the CIA is now I guess an admitted
they have bought journalists in the past
but you also pointed out that a lot of
events were staged for the benefit of
the press and stories are core spoon-fed
to the press by the CIA and most of
these go unchallenged well there's a
social relationship and class
relationship with the upper people who
control the newspapers that only
persuade now the old boy network this
has been pointed up but you know many
months back when they were talking about
CIA and press relationships
well they press people the top members
of the press meet in the Bilderberg
Group along with members of the CIA
they're in the same social clubs they
know each other on a personal basis so
naturally there's going to be a revenge
what what evolves is the end result of
all this is that the CIA's existence in
the 50s and the 60s when it gallops so
gated it got so far out of line drugs
sex experiments on unwitting American
guinea pigs assassination attempts of
world leaders successful some successful
and and many many crimes that you can
only describe as depraved and yet Nam
war and the Angora war and coos and
these things were were permissible this
this evolution of this organization was
possible only with the indulgence of the
press if the press had been alert had
been smoking this organization out had
been reporting that the CIA is doing
this that and the other it could never
have gotten by with it this is my big
disappointment now is to see the nation
the establishment turning and the press
establishment this is what I said over
the phone just yesterday I think the
last conversation was in this series of
conversations was just that that we're
heading right back where we were with
the indulgence of the press the press is
cooperating with the government to put
the seei back in action just where it
was mind you we've gone through all of
these exposures of 1975 and 76 and and
the CIA's charter has actually been
expanded in the last three years since
then well John you're talking about the
press and the fact that they have not
performed this watchdog
function even when they have the
opportunity such as your letter to the
New York Times tell us about that well
there have been there been a couple I
don't I don't have the time to spend a
lot of time writing all the letters that
occurred to me obviously I think we all
have that syndrome of reading something
say oh I'd like to answer that myself
and occasionally I read something and I
really do feel like I have something
valid to say but last year I got a call
from an editor of The New York Times who
said that they had run an article from
congressman Stratton a letter calling
for a stronger expanded CI and deploring
the fact that the nation was weak
because the see I was in trouble it was
broken down they had run a letter from
Admiral Turner saying don't worry about
it we need help we need your support but
but we're still out there pitching so
don't don't worry about it too much but
give us your help and this guy who's I
believe mind and heart are pretty honest
and pretty much in the right place call
me and he said we got to have somebody
come in and say wait a minute you know
the other side of that is is calling for
a closure of the CIA and so why don't
you write that one Stockwell and I spent
three weeks I didn't do anything else I
wrote this thing and I rewrote it I
talked to him on the phone and rewrote
it I rewrote it I rewrote it I rewrote
it and they never ran it did I order
tell you why I talked to him endlessly
but essentially it boiled down at the
end he quit returning my phone calls
because he was getting embarrassed
because essentially the one editor comes
up with an article he likes and he shops
it around the other editors and if they
all sort of agree it gets momentum going
until the boss says okay let's run with
it and he couldn't get the momentum that
they just weren't going to run an
article that was anti CI and they did
not and my own experience by the way in
dealing with the New York Times that
time and three other occasions and
dealing with Washington Post or I've
also published is that the New York
Times is is at least ten times as
enlightened as the Washington Post
well this most recent letter which you
wrote to the New York Times also reveals
the same type of thinking you wrote to
them about the Cuban situation
did you not yes I I wrote to him about
the Cuban situation and I must admit
this time I was wiser and more
experienced and also the editor that I
was talking to is quite candid with me
and quite straightforward and he told me
the reasons quite promptly why they
couldn't run it it was very frustrating
to me because I thought it should be run
and he would say he agreed and then he
would say but it's not going to run
that's obviously just you know and that
that small group of people that article
was not going to get priority over the
others but the same principle is that no
one has pointed out on in an
international organ a Western
international organ that this thing
started with a CI operation which got
out of hand it was a little bit more
successful in the CIA ever dreamed and
politics
we're not playing with little secret
operations that effect no one our
economic problems now are greatly tied
to this 165 billion dollar disaster in
Vietnam that was a CI operation for at
least seven years before we began an
overt military campaign the the CIA was
deeply involved in a secret war in
Southeast Asia and trying to get the
United States government involved the
first whistleblower was a gentleman
named Paul sacra who was not because of
the mood of the nation and the press and
whatnot was not given an audience he did
not succeed in speaking out he didn't
have quite the whatever it takes to
write a book and get it published but he
resigned his job in the early 60s in
protest over the CIA's efforts to lobby
to [ __ ] the American public about
what was happening in Vietnam and he
quit because the station in Saigon was
putting out false information
consciously discussing their ploys to
lobby to get the Americans to wake up to
the threat and do quote the right thing
the CIA might remember has published by
then it had published a couple of
thousand english-language books that
means for American consumption that were
secretly published by the CIA paying
someone to write a book to end and many
of those books at that time we're about
Vietnam in Angola we would not have had
that war I warrant if there'd been
public debate you had Henry Kissinger
and Bill cobia the CI wanted this war
and they got it because they were able
to do it in secrecy they lied to the
Senate in order to get it done the
American interests that were in Angola
were significant you had Gulf oil and
Boeing doing business with the Angolan
government they were not permitted to
vote to disgust participate in the
decision to go to war in Angola
they were distressed when it happened
when they found out they were they were
put out of business temporarily by this
secret war the American churches had
extensive missionary organizations
inside Angola and they were not
permitted to participate in the decision
to go into Angola and and of course the
American scholars who were working in
both traveling the exchanges they were
not permitted to participate you had two
individuals engineered this war who had
never been to Angola and one of them had
never set foot in Africa in his life
neither of them were Africanist even and
they engineered a war and got it done
because of secrecy you know I watch on
things like this Tom Schneider show on
NBC where the the Turner is is on and
given a national primetime to say that
people who attack the CIA like Stockwell
and others bill Shipp and others are
unamerican they're traitors was his word
in his eyes glinted when I said that and
that's a fellow who is America Admiral
Turner the director of the CIA now who
is American Turner insists on secrecy
and he's lobbying for laws to put people
like me in jail for going to the
American people and telling what we've
done in America's name with America's
tax dollars and I ask you who is
American who is the traitor to the
American system the John stockwell's and
Frank's nips and others who are
exercising the American principle of
participating of working together to
discuss what our country is doing and
try to influence it lord knows I might
be wrong in my position towards Angoor
or any position in the world but it's
the American process to stand up and
thrash it